[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia india y pakistán celebran en
agosto sus independencias a la vez que
recuerdan los traumáticos eventos que
ocurrieron durante la separación de dos
países que alguna vez conformaron la
gran india británica con la partida de
los ingleses las diferencias de credo
detonaron en
1947 un genocidio religioso que acabó
con la vida de entre 500.000 hasta más
de un millón de personas
la india de mediados del siglo 20 era el
hogar de alrededor de 400 millones de
personas de las cuales un 75 por ciento
eran hindúes o sea pertenecientes al
hinduismo una antiquísima religión
politeísta cuyo panteón de deidades lo
conforman brahma vishnú y shiva
[Música]
el 15% restante de la población era
musulmán religión monoteísta cuyos
fieles le profesan devoción a un único
dios alá
tanto hindúes como musulmanes sufrieron
con la partición de india y pakistán la
mayor migración en masa de la que se
tenga registro en la historia de la
humanidad con alrededor de 14 millones
de personas cruzando de un territorio a
otro por cuenta de su religión como
antecedente sabemos que desde el año
1900 cuando los británicos privilegiaron
el indi como la lengua oficial de todo
el territorio los musulmanes temieron
que su cultura y su religión se
suprimiera de manera que los fieles al
islam consideraron que sus intereses
sociales y políticos debían estar
totalmente separados de aquellos de los
hindúes
durante la segunda guerra mundial el
movimiento de independencia de la india
que fue liderado por mahatma gandhi
cobró gran relevancia frente al
desgastado imperio británico que luchaba
contra los nazis unos años en que los
musulmanes ganaron importante terreno en
las elecciones provinciales y cada vez
más se consolidaba la idea de un estado
musulmán separado de un estado hindú
quien representaba esta idea era el
abogado y político muhammad ali jinnah
gina era el líder del partido de la liga
musulmana quien con la resolución de la
force de 1940 había dejado estipulado el
afán de crear una nación enteramente
musulmana la nación de pakistán en
completa oposición estaban negro el
líder del congreso nacional de la india
junto a gandhi quienes rechazaron la
partición de la india y el movimiento
nacionalista musulmán pero los intereses
indios de mantener una sola nación se
truncaron cuando los propios ingleses
antes de abandonar el raso régimen
colonial le apostaron a las demandas de
los musulmanes y ejecute en la partición
del país
durante cinco semanas civil radcliffe un
abogado escogido por las autoridades
británicas tuvo bajo su control el
trazado de una de las fronteras más
polémicas de la historia contemporánea
fueron dos mil 900 kilómetros de
separación entre el subcontinente indio
y la región occidental del punjab que
daría su nombre a pakistán de otra parte
ratcliffe también había diseccionado del
territorio hindú una porción de tierra
del estado de bengala también de mayoría
musulmana que quedaría bajo el control
de pakistán pero resulta inoperante que
los dos nuevos territorios musulmanes
estuvieran separados uno del otro por
más de 2.000 kilómetros de manera que la
partición fue masivamente criticada en
todo caso para llenar se había cumplido
su sueño propuesto en la conferencia de
la liga en la jove cientos cuarenta de
un estado musulmán separado de un estado
hindú de esta manera el 14 de agosto de
1947 pakistán nació como un estado nuevo
con china
primer ministro un día después el 15 de
agosto negro hizo lo propio y proclamó
la independencia de la india en este
momento de la historia a miles de
familias musulmanas que habían vivido
por décadas en la india emprendieron un
viaje para establecerse en pakistán al
mismo tiempo que familias hindúes en
territorio pakistaní cruzaron al nuevo y
de marcado territorio indio la cifra
emigrante se estableció entre 10 a 15
millones de los cuales los más pobres
que eran la mayoría viajaron a pie las
clases medias lo hicieron en trenes y
las clases acomodadas en avión y coches
el problema derivó en que las regiones
fronterizas albergado en miles de
soldados desmovilizados que estaban
enardecidos por los sentimientos
nacionalistas de un lado y del otro de
modo que se organizaron en milicias para
atacar en masa a pueblos trenes y
concentraciones de emigrantes desde
agosto hasta finales de
1947 con la independencia de ambos
países también se detonó una guerra por
el control de la región de cachemira
conflicto que hasta hoy no se ha logrado
resolver entristecido por las masacres
los trenes llenos de cadáveres y la
muerte de entre 500.000 y más de un
millón de personas mahatma gandhi
también fue alcanzado por la violencia
nacionalista cuando en enero de 1948 fue
asesinado por un extremista indio que
rechazaba su política de tolerancia
entre religiones en 1971 pakistán del
este lo que antiguamente era el estado
de bengala se independizó de pakistán y
se conformó como un nuevo país
bangladesh india y pakistán jamás
limaron asperezas y hasta hoy se
mantiene un trauma por la tragedia
humana que se vivió durante la partición
aquel evento que coincide con las
independencias de ambos países así
concluimos hoy andrés suárez jaramillo
gracias por compartir y comentar estas
historias que las encuentran en los
programas de france 24 punto com
[Música]